[Music]
in another busy transfer window it's
clear there's no cost of living crisis
in the Premier League as English
football has become even more lucrative
clubs have dished out almost 3 billion
pounds in the last year on transfer fees
four times more than any other country
so where is the cash from who's getting
rich and what do the spending rules
allow
[Music]
yes the English Premier League has
become one of the biggest Sports and
brands in the world and with that status
brings money the Premier League
generates three and a half billion
pounds a season double closest rival La
Liga in Spain with more income now
coming from overseas broadcasters
including Sky News parent company
Comcast
some of the richest people and countries
in the world are attracted to the
Premier League
recently Newcastle were bought by Saudi
Arabia Manchester city has seen
remarkable success in the past decade
thanks to investment from the UAE and
the club behind me Chelsea built the
success from the money of Russian
billionaire Roman Abramovich until he
was forced to sell up after the invasion
of Ukraine
some of the biggest transfer deals in
the Premier League have been in recent
years with the likes of Jack grealish
and romelu Lukaku costing clubs close to
100 million pounds each
it's not just the players and clubs
raking it in
football agents can receive tens of
millions from a single transfer agents
are there to represent players and
negotiate on behalf of them as clubs the
huge fees involved led to a rise in
so-called super agents the likes of
Jorge Mendes for example have made
Millions for clinching lavish deals for
high-profile clients like Jose Mourinho
and Cristiano Ronaldo
while it sometimes feels that spending
is out of control there are actually
rules restricting how much clubs can
Splash out
UEFA launched Financial fair play in
2011 to prevent unfettered splurges on
players clubs can still spend heavily
but counterbalance with legitimate
sources of income losses Allowed by
clubs have doubled to about 50 million
pounds over three years one accounting
mechanism to limit the impact is signing
up players to long-term deals as Chelsea
have done to spread the cost
kylo Modric was signed for 88 million
pounds on an eight and a half year
contract so that appears around 10
million pounds each year on their
accounts
[Music]
the Premier League is facing challenges
the impact globally of the pandemic on
the economy means bills are rising three
years on from brexit making signings
from Europe can be harder and British
players can be costlier but there's no
sign of spending in English football
slowing down